ratten sind soziale tiere das größte
teleskop der welt zerstört kultur und
warum staunende menschen hilfsbereiter
sind das sind nur drei der fünf dm in
den pigs um top five news jetzt bei dem
anblick einer ratte erschrecken oder
wenden sich viele menschen ab die rate
hat nicht gerade einen guten stand in
der geschichte der menschheit sie
brachte oft krankheiten mit sich doch
forscher sind jetzt auch ganz andere
seiten der rate gestoßen
sie ist sozial und sehr freundlich
gegenüber ihren artgenossen eingestellt
zwei ratten zeigten den forschern wie
sozial sie eingestellt sind die forscher
der quandts alkuin university setzen die
ratten in zwei von drei kleinen
abgetrennten räumen
im ersten raum war ein kleines
wasserbecken im zweiten raum war nichts
und im dritten raum befand sich
schokolade
die drei räume waren durch zwei türen
verbunden
die razzia wurde in den raum mit dem
wassergesetz die rate b kam in den
leeren raum verstand schnell dass ich bi
in einer misslichen lage befand und
bemühte sich sofort die tür zu öffnen um
tee zu sich zu holen
bei der ganzen rettungsaktion wurde die
schokolade im dritten raum total
ignoriert der klimawandel hinterlässt
auch hier in deutschland seine spuren
sehr viel stärkere spuren als von vielen
angenommen wie sich der klimawandel auf
unser land auswirkt geht aus den
monitoring berichten der bundesregierung
sehr gut hervor
in der veröffentlichung der deutschen
bundesregierung heißt es dass neben der
immer weiter ansteigenden hitze auch die
nicht national angesiedelten pflanzen
und tierarten der natur und den menschen
den werden schwierigkeiten bereitet
viele krankheiten die tiere aus
südlichen ländern mitbringen können
hierzulande noch nicht wirklich
routinemäßig behandelt werden und unsere
regionalen pflanzen werden oft von den
neuen arten zerstört
von einer interministeriellen gruppe
wurden hunderte zahlen und daten wie zum
beispiel die zahl der hitze toten und so
weiter analysiert ziel der analyse den
behörden möglichst viele informationen
bereitzustellen um schnelle und
effektive gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen zu
können
wer hat sich nicht schon einmal gefragt
warum zebrastreifen haben und zu was sie
eigentlich die die ökologin brender
larsen hat eine neue antwort darauf
gefunden temperaturregulierung
bisherigen forschungen zufolge dienen
die streifen der insektenabwehr die
lokal vorherrschende cc fliege stört
diese musste ring musste um so sehr dass
sie abstand von den tieren nehme das
sieht jörissen von der university of
california anders mit ihrem team stellte
sie die these der insektenabwehr unter
die probe
sie konnten jedoch keine verbindung
zwischen den zebrastreifen und der
darauf folgenden reaktionen der insekten
finden die forscher analysierten
daraufhin ihre eigenen vermutungen
zebrastreifen dienen zur
temperaturregulierung tatsächlich konnte
das team beobachten dass zebras in
warmen regionen andere viel intensivere
streifen haben als die tiere in kälteren
regionen der luftstrom zwischen den
streifen habe eine kühlende funktion
naja vielleicht gibt es ja mehrere
gründe für die zebrastreifen das tmt
wird das größte teleskop der welt ganze
30 meter lang es gibt jedoch probleme
der geplante standort mauna kea manak er
ist ein ruhender vulkan der weiße berg
wer von den hawaiianischen bewohnern
genannt wird einer der wichtigsten
kulturellen begegnungsstätten der dort
lebenden menschen nicht tnt der
sprengstoff sondern tmt soll diesen berg
jetzt ruinieren das seti meter teleskop
wird bis 2022 fertiggestellt insofern
alles gut läuft gebaut soll es eben
genau auf diesem gipfel des mauna kea
und das ist der grund der heftigen
proteste die einen sehen das teleskop
als ersten schritt zu mehr reichtum und
anerkennung des landes die anderen
halten alles für eine einzige zerstörung
der kultur und der umwelt der berg geben
vielen käfern und vögeln platz zum
wohnen und ist alten erzählungen zufolge
der erste sohn von der ert mutter papa
genau inwieweit sich kultur und umwelt
gegen technologie und fortschritt
durchsetzen können muss vermutlich
demnächst ein rechtsspruch entscheiden
du lässt sich leicht beeindrucken und
staunt gerne dann bist du nach der
meinung von psychologen aus amerika ein
hilfsbereiter und sozialer teil unserer
gesellschaft denn dann nimmt man sich
aus dem fokus und stellt andere in das
zentrum der aufmerksamkeit dieses sich
zurücknehmen fördert die sozialen
veranlagung des menschen auf dieses
resultat sind die wissenschaftler der
university of california in irvine durch
mehrere versuche gekommen das team um
paul pif führte mit über 2000 probanden
ein experiment aus jeder der teilnehmer
bekam den ersten versuch 10 lotterielose
aufgabe war sie entweder für sich zu
behalten oder lose davon zu verschenken
die probanden die sich leichter
beeindrucken lassen verschenkten
häufiger ihre lose als die anderen im
zweiten versuch schauten die probanden
gemeinsam filme
wer häufiger über die inhalte der filme
staunte dem war es enorm wichtig einen
guten und freundschaftlichen stand in
der gruppenkonstellation zu haben unsere
forschung weist darauf hin dass es mehr
hilfe und mehr rücksicht gebe wenn die
menschen öfter staunen werden würden so
tief manchmal verhält man vor lauter
begeisterung und erstaunen in langes
schweigen menschen die an dieser
krankheit mutismus leiden wiederum
verfallen in ewiges schweigen aufgrund
ihrer erkrankung näheres zu diesem
wirklich spannenden thema und kaum
bekannten thema erfahrt ihr in dem video
hier oben zu rap und zum blog da kommt
ihr hier unten und sack war gehört ihr
zu denen die oft über dinge staunen und
könnt ihr die vorhin genannte theorie in
irgendeiner weise bestätigen
diskutiertes mal in den kommentaren und
ich kann noch sagen bis dann bleibt dran